this is the rescue boat bought by banksy
the louise michelle marooned in the
mediterranean because it was dangerously
overcrowded
with migrants more than 200 reportedly
on board
today they were moved most of them
transferred to a much
larger boat run by the german group sea
watch which
regularly rescues people from the sea
but now the german boat is struggling to
find somewhere that it is allowed to
dock
and which would be considered a safe
place for those aboard who are seeking
asylum
the situation on board is quite cramped
to be honest
we are in between malta and italy those
are the closest safe ports and by the
law of the sea um
it is meant that the closest safe ports
are the ports where the people
rescued at sea need to be disembarked uh
of course the north african reports
cannot be regarded as safe for asylum
seekers and refugees
fleeing just these shores
before the sea watch had arrived 49
vulnerable migrants mostly women and
children
had been taken from the louise michel to
the italian island of lampedusa by the
italian coast guard
but this hearse a reminder of the
perilous undertone to all this
over the past decade lampedusa has
become used to migrants
and with this new influx there is
simmering resentment
a demonstration here a sense of anger
many on this island feel abandoned and
ignored
we are not understanding anything here
in lampedusa we are all dying here
the migrants are not going away because
they are left alone
we are all in this together tonight lam
producer says
enough migration is
a potent political topic in italy today
it brought
more tragedy four migrants dying as
their boat caught fire near calabria in
the south
how to deal fairly with migration is a
familiar
and profound problem for all of europe
the challenge
is coming up with a solution adam
parsons sky news